think I'm in love with Rose burn just
gonna get that out of the way right now
she's funny she's sexy she's talented
Rose burn tweet me or something she's
never gonna see this [ __ ]
neighbors so neighbors is a comedy
starring Seth Rogen is Zac Efron Seth
Rogen's married to way out of his league
Rose Byrne seriously happens let that
sink in married how because the script
says he has to be point is they have a
kid together and you feel like they're
transitioning into your Parenthood but
then they get new neighbors and it's a
frat house yeah a frat house next to
parents with a child you just want the
kid to sleep through the night us we
have a Clash of the Titans and a really
enjoyable movie I thought it was gonna
be the comment all right they're going
after them they're going after them
they're just pranking each other back
and forth which it really is a lot of it
the movie has more heart than that
that's what I liked about it first of
all with Zac Efron okay statistically
speaking I think it's actually a
mathematical statistic that one out of
every 100 Disney kids might not crash
and burn in their lives after this movie
I feel like Zac Efron could be the guy
he could be like the next Bradley Cooper
maybe if he makes really good choices
and has a really good agent and he's
smart about it as long as he doesn't
become lunch bag head puppet man I think
you'll be fine
Zac Efron's good in the movie he's
likable when he wants to be likable he's
douchey when he wants to be douchey but
deep down underneath you feel like
there's this kid who just doesn't know
what he wants to do with his life and
you almost pity him some messed up
reason I was like oh poor bastard you
fix up this [ __ ] matters a dozen Seth
Rogen in the movie plays Seth Rogen in
the movie seriously Seth Rogen is the
same Seth Rogen character in most of his
movies he's Seth Rogen because is so
damn well you're like all right yeah
okay we love him for being the same damn
thing in person and everything he's in
Rose Byrne was really great in the movie
too like I said now I'm in love with her
I suppose even after bridesmaids I
didn't appreciate how good she is at
comedy I just thought in bridesmaids I'm
like okay she plays the [ __ ] chick so
she's not the outgoing one but on this
one you'll like no Rose burns actually
funny
you feel like she'd be a fun person to
hang out with and then you just want to
hang out with her yeah [ __ ] you Seth
Rogen I think I love most about this
movies it knew what it was you know
those Judd Apatow comedies not
the guy can't make good movies I'm
saying a lot of the times have walked
out of those movies and I'm like that
movies - half an hour too long you know
what I was talking about yet this movie
doesn't do that this movies like no we
know we're supposed to be 90 minutes
long so we're 90 minutes long but they
still find ways to shoehorn heart in
there yeah shoehorn the Green Goblin is
in the movie for five minutes I'm gonna
get pissed shoehorned some heartfelt
moments in there I'm gonna be like okay
all right all right but wasn't a lot I
didn't like I enjoyed this [ __ ] out of
the movie it's like that summertime
comedy that you want to see every summer
every summer there's one there's that
one comedy where you're like yeah thank
you comedies for being funny still so
neighbors was funny I liked the cast I
liked the chemistry within the cast I
liked the jokes I liked the competition
the two houses have going at each other
I like the absurdity of Emmy it's an
absurd movie for sure I should can't
happen in real life it just can't but it
was fun to watch in the end I will say
neighbors is worth buying on blu-ray
laughed my ass off I have very little
nitpicks about it that's called blu-ray
funniest movie I've seen all year that's
for sure but some neighbors have you
seen it what did you think about it what
are we that comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more